you get mistaken and I can't believe
this how does someone who has two Oscars
at home get mistaken for someone else
you get mistaken for Jennifer Garner is
that right I do yeah I do I do I in fact
people will get angry at me because they
think that I'm just trying not to sign
an autograph for them or take a picture
oh they'll say hey Jennifer said don't
be like oh god I'm such a big fan I love
you an alias yeah and I'm like oh please
I know you know you're busy with your
family but please and I'm like not I'm
not Jennifer like please be like really
even they're like she's a [ __ ] they
said don't be don't be a [ __ ] oh my god
I was like I didn't want to give her a
bad name so I can hopefully maybe
someone will say someday that's not
Jennifer Garner yeah I I asked her I
think I told her and she said oh my god
I get that all the time too I said as
Jennifer Garner no oh with you if
someone thinks I'm a different celebrity
I just borrow a lot of money that's what
I did whoa oh oh I'm good for it just
hop me down I don't think I get mistaken
for anybody now it's not true
snuffleupagus
you